- Le gouvernement fédéral
refuse de ratifier
le protocole de Kyoto.
- Été 2001, Steven Guilbeault
participe à un coup d'éclat
qui le fera connaître
du grand public.
- À Toronto, deux membres
de Greenpeace n'ont pas hésité
à escalader la tour CN afin
d'y déployer une bannière
protestant contre le
réchauffement de la planète.
- Mais son souvenir le plus
lointain d'engagement pour
l'environnement remonte
à l'enfance, lorsque des arbres
doivent être coupés derrière
chez lui pour construire
des maisons.
- Avec la permission de ma mère,
je... j'en ai choisi un
et je suis grimpé. Et je suis
resté là des heures et des
heures. Et cette journée-là,
cet arbre-là, ils n'ont pas pu
le couper. Alors...
ça a été le début.
- Pour eux, l'environnement...
- Dans les années 90, il fonde
l'ONG Équiterre avec une autre
figure de proue du mouvement
environnemental québécois,
Laure Waridel.
LAURE WARIDEL,
cofondatrice, Équiterre
- Steven représentait vraiment
le pragmatisme. C'est quelqu'un
qui est en mode solution,
qui n'a pas peur de faire
des compromis aussi. Ce qui a pu
causer certaines frictions
à certains moments avec d'autres
écologistes, qui jugeaient
que certains compromis
n'étaient pas acceptables.
- Parmi les premiers ministres
de l'Environnement à prendre
ensuite la parole...
- Dans les années qui suivent,
il est parfois le caillou dans
la chaussure des gouvernements
qui ne s'engagent pas
suffisamment pour combattre
les changements climatiques.
Comme au sommet de Kyoto.
- Les États-Unis d'Amérique
sont toujours pris en otage
par le lobby des combustibles
fossiles.
- Et à Copenhague, Dimitri
Soudas, l'attaché de presse
de Stephen Harper, alors
premier ministre du Canada,
l'accuse faussement d'être
l'auteur d'un canular.
- Plusieurs vous voyaient
peut-être au sein
de l'appareil gouvernemental.
- Reste qu'il est aussi courtisé
par tous les ordres
de gouvernement pendant
de nombreuses années.
- Très, très, très heureux...
- C'est finalement en 2019 qu'il
répondra à l'appel du libéral
fédéral Justin Trudeau.
Deux ans plus tard, il devient
ministre de l'Environnement.
NICOLAS HULOT, ancien min.
français Transition écologique
- Je ne veux plus me mentir,
je prends la décision
de quitter le gouvernement.
- Le saut en politique
n'a pas toujours souri
aux environnementalistes.
Le Français Nicolas Hulot
a rapidement démissionné
de ses fonctions de ministre
de la Transition écologique
et solidaire.
KAREL MAYRAND,
PDG, Fondation du Grand Montréal
- Nicolas Hulot n'avait pas
l'expérience du travail
politique. Stephen a fait
ce travail-là depuis... bien,
littéralement deux décennies.
Et donc, il est capable
de travailler à l'intérieur
des institutions pour faire
avancer ses objectifs.
- Le passé militant du nouveau
ministre de l'Environnement
ne rassure toutefois pas
tout le monde.
JASON KENNEY,
premier ministre de l'Alberta
- Si monsieur Guilbeault suit
les politiques qu'il a appuyées
en tant que militant auparavant,
ce sera un désastre
pour l'économie canadienne.
- Stephen Guilbeault participera
pour la 19e fois à la Conférence
des Nations Unies sur
les changements climatiques,
mais pour la première fois,
ce sera en tant que ministre
de l'Environnement.
Ici Pasquale Harrison-Julien,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.
Un aut